The Upper Moon One Demon Kokushibo was the second
strongest living character in all of demon slayer,
just behind the demon king Muzan. And his power
is so incredibly overwhelming that at the end of
the manga it took three of the strongest
Hashira to finally defeat him. However,
since he used to be a Demon Slayer
himself, I’ve always wondered what
would have happened if Kokushibo somehow broke
free of Muzan’s control and became a good demon.
And before explaining how Kokushibo would affect
the end of the manga, we have to ask the very
vitally important question of how would Kokushibo
become good? Since he is currently a demon,
it is normally impossible for him to betray
Muzan. That is because it is well known that
Muzan can literally kill any demon with just
a single thought. But the manga has shown us
that there are a few important exceptions
which we will discuss in just a moment.
So I see two options for how Kokushibo could
become good. The first realistic option is
that he never turns into a demon in the first
place, and fights Muzan alongside his brother
five hundred years ago. The second option involves
Tanjiro and we’ll discuss that in just a moment,
but in case you forgot, in chapter 174 we learn
that Kokushibo is actually the brother of THE MOST
POWERFUL Demon Slayer in history, Yoriichi.
And the reason that Kokushibo became a demon
in the first place was because at that time
all of the demon slayers who had unlocked the
Demon Slayer Mark eventually died by the time
they turned twenty-five. Of course, Kokushibo
didn’t want to die, so when he encountered
Muzan he agreed to become a demon to survive.
However, what if Kokushibo instead accepted his
fate, remained a human, and instead teamed up
with his brother to defeat Muzan? Now we know that
Yoriichi was FULLY capable of defeating Muzan on
his own, so with the help of his brother, who
was a powerful demon slayer in his own right,
they should easily be able to defeat Muzan,
right??? Well, while that is certainly possible,
we have to remember that as a human
Kokushibo is nowhere near the level
of his brother or the demon king. So I
think he would be an easy target for Muzan,
which might lead to Yoriichi being distracted
and getting killed trying to save his brother.
Which is the worst possible outcome because
then Tanjiro would have no chance of learning
Sun Breathing. So while this battle honestly
could go either way, there is no guarantee that
Kokushibo staying human and helping his brother
would allow them to take down the demon king.
But with that option out of the way, let’s
get to the much more interesting scenario,
where Kokushibo plays a vital role in taking down
Muzan at the end of the manga. In this scenario,
Kokushibo still becomes a demon to survive the
Demon Slayer Mark’s curse. And I already know
that people in the comments are going to spam
“Haha, you idiot Ohara, don’t you know that
demons can’t betray Muzan?”. Well, yes, that is
normally true, but there are some exceptions. The
way Kokushibo could break free is the same way
this friendly doctor Tamayo did in chapter 187.
While we’re not exactly sure how this happened,
Tamayo gained her freedom through some combination
of her intense hatred of Muzan and the fact
that Muzan was nearly killed by Yoriichi. So if
Kokushibo also desperately wanted to be
free, and Muzan had another near-death
encounter with Yoriichi, then I think he
could break out of Muzan’s control too.
Another option for him to gain
his freedom is also related to
Tamayo. As we see early on in the
story, she turned her assistant,
Yushiro, into a demon all by herself. This is
important because Yushiro has NEVER been under
Muzan’s control, which means that if the
human Kokushibo was looking for a way to
live and somehow encountered Tamayo, then
she could turn him into a demon as well.
Now both of these require some
luck and changes in the story,
but that’s kinda the point of a What If
scenario. So let’s assume that Kokushibo
is a demon BUT he is free of Muzan’s control.
Now remember this is still 500 years ago and he
isn’t strong enough to take on Muzan himself
yet, so what in the world is he going to do
to help the current Demon Slayers? Well, he
could work with Tamayo or he could go into
hiding. There’s also a very real possibility
that Muzan would try to hunt down Kokushibo,
but since Tamayo and Yushiro were able to hide for
500 years, let’s assume Kokushibo could as well.
Now let’s skip ahead through the centuries.
Kokushibo probably wouldn’t reveal himself
unless he thought there was a serious chance
to defeat Muzan, which probably wouldn’t happen
until Tanjiro and Nezuko save Tamayo during the
Asakusa Arc. And it is possible that Kokushibo
witnesses the event himself, or maybe Tamayo sends
him a message about the interesting siblings,
but either way, Kokushibo will be
keeping an eye on Tanjiro and Nezuko.
Which is going to ABSOLUTELY change everything
when Tanjiro first reveals his ability to use
Sun Breathing during his fight against
the Spider Demon Rui. Which, by the way,
what a legendary episode. And at this moment,
Kokushibo will finally feel some hope that a
new generation of demon slayers has arrived
to take down Muzan. So Kokushibo might reveal
himself to Tanjiro now, or he might wait until
the young slayer unlocks the demon slayer mark
during the Entertainment District arc, but either
way, Kokushibo will meet with Tanjiro very soon.
And honestly, meeting Kokushibo would be pretty
terrifying for anyone. Just look at his face,
though I suppose he could change his form
since he is a powerful demon. But I think
the best way for him to meet Tanjiro would be
if Tamayo invited the siblings to come visit.
That way Kokushibo could reveal himself to Tanjiro
while having Tamayo back up his claims that he is
actually a good demon. And knowing Tanjiro, once
Kokushibo has a chance to explain who he is and
that he wants to take down Muzan, I simply
cannot see him refusing the demon’s help.
However, this next part of the scenario has
the potential to blow up everything. Because
when Kokushibo offers to train Tanjiro, I don’t
think the young demon slayer would want to keep
this a secret from the Demon Slayer Corps.
Which means that Kokushibo would first need
to come to the Demon Slayer headquarters.
So throw 500 years of hiding in the trash,
because it’s time for him to reveal himself
to the world. So let’s assume that he agrees,
and the leader of the Demon Slayer Corps,
Kagaya Ubuyashiki, allows him to come - which
is also debatable - but this is going to lead
to a mind-blowing encounter with the Hashira.
Because remember that Kokushibo chose to become
a demon five hundred years ago. Plus the Demon
slayers were nearly wiped out by Muzan during
this era. So there is going to be some bad blood
no matter what. And when you throw a certifiably
insane hashira like Sanemi in front of a demon
like Kokushibo, I don’t think any words will keep
the wind hashira from charging in and trying to
chop Kokushibo’s head off. Seriously, just look at
what he did to Nezuko, who was just a little girl.
Now I don’t think there is any chance Sanemi
succeeds, although it is fair to say that this
version of Kokushibo probably isn’t as powerful
if he stopped eating humans. Regardless he would
still be an incredibly strong demon who
has been training for five hundred years,
and it would likely take multiple Hashira to
take him down. However, I don’t think Kagaya
would let that happen since he invited him,
so after a few sword clashes he orders the
fighting to stop and for you to subscribe to
the channel for more anime content like this.
But now Kokushibo can finally explain who he
is and that he wants to take down Muzan. And
not JUST as a fighter, but honestly he would
probably make a much bigger difference as a
teacher because he could show them many of
the secrets of the old Demon Slayer Corps.
This includes some abilities that they already
know such as Total Concentration Breathing,
but also others such as being able to see the
Transparent World and even more information about
the Demon Slayer Mark. And man, this is going to
DRAMATICALLY change the final clash against Muzan.
However, I still don’t think many of the
Hashira would want to train with a demon,
but I’m sure Tanjiro would accept with Kagaya’s
approval, especially because Kokushibo could show
him more about Sun Breathing since his brother
invented it 500 years ago. Zenitsu and Inosuke
would probably also join in the training,
and even though they might not be able to
unlock access to the transparent world or the
full demon slayer mark just by practicing,
I am 100 percent sure that training with
a super strong 500 year old demon would
give all three of them an incredible
power boost going into the next arc.
And with a greater mastery of Sun Breathing
and Total Concentration breathing, Tanjiro is
absolutely going to crush the demons during the
Swordsmith Village arc. In fact, Tanjiro’s new
powers might let him take out the Upper Moon 4
Hantengu’s true body and his emotion-based forms
before they can even combine into their strongest
form. And when the Love Hashira Mitsuri and the
Mist Hashira Murichiro see just how powerful
Tanjiro has become since training with Kokushibo,
I think this will finally convince the other
Hashira to learn from Kokushibo. Who knows,
maybe Tanjiro would even be strong enough to
officially become a Hashira at this point.
Which is honestly just the start of how much this
good version of Kokushibo will change the story,
but from this point let’s assume that Muzan still
finds out about Nezuko’s resistance to the sun,
so the plot progresses mostly unchanged.
This leads to another intense training
arc before the Demon Slayer Corps
are then attacked by the Muzan.
Alongside the demon king are the remaining Upper
Moon demons, including a brand new demon, since
Kokushibo is not on their side. As for who would
be the new Upper Moon One, it could honestly go a
few different ways. The easiest thing would be for
the old Upper Moon 2 Doma to simply be promoted
with Akaza moving up behind him to number two. Or
the other option is that Muzan convinced another
strong demon slayer to join his side and this
new demon became Upper Moon one. Either way,
Kokushibo’s presence during the final battle
is going to change things in SO MANY WAYS.
The start of this battle will go as usual, since
Muzan was able to catch the Demon Slayers by
surprise in the original story. This means that
Kagaya still talks with Muzan and eventually
blows himself up. Then Tamayo poisons Muzan. At
this point, the Demon Slayers arrive along with
Kokushibo, and this is where things start to go
absolutely crazy. Muzan is furious that multiple
demons are siding with the Demon Slayers, and he
is especially pissed off when he recognizes that
Kokushibo is Yoriichi’s brother. So he’d probably
go berserk and try to kill them all instantly,
but since everyone here is now stronger
because of their training with Kokushibo,
they can defend against the attack without
anyone getting hurt. Then Kokushibo might be
able to occupy Muzan long enough for the
other demon slayers to deal significant
damage. But in the end, I think this version of
Kokushibo is weaker than in the original story,
so they probably wouldn’t be
able to defeat Muzan right here.
But that’s just the start of the battle because
then Muzan drops them into the Infinity Castle
so that he can recover from Tamayo’s poison. This
splits up the Demon Slayers to fight against the
Upper Moon Demons. And here is where we have some
interesting choices. Because originally Tanjiro
and the water hashira Giyu fought against Akaza;
the insect hashira Shinobu, her apprentice Kanao,
and Inosuke fought against Doma; and Muichiro,
Genya, Sanemi, and the Stone Hashira Gyomei fought
against Kokushibo. But since Kokushibo is on
the Demon Slayer Corps side now, one of two
things could occur. First Kokushibo could fight
against whatever new demon is the Upper Moon 1.
And this is a bit tricky since normally demons
can’t kill each other with sunlight, but let’s
assume that Kokushibo can use a Nichirin blade
and can kill demons. That would free up Muichiro,
Genya, Sanemi, and Gyomei to help the others.
Or the other option is those four could still
fight whatever new demon is the upper
moon one, while Kokushibo helps fight
some of the other strong demons. Whatever
the case, there are more strong fighters
to help with the battles, so we could even
see Shinobu and Muichiro survive this time.
Now by the time, Yushiro forces everyone out of
the Infinity Castle, I think there is a strong
chance that almost all of the Hashira are still
alive. Maybe only Genya dies, but overall the
Demon Slayers are in a much stronger position
to fight Muzan for Round Two. And thanks to
Kokushibo’s training, I think most of them
would be able to see the transparent world,
which would greatly help them defend against
Muzan’s unbelievably fast tentacle attacks.
Which leads us to the epic final clash, which
honestly is still going to be unbelievably
difficult. At this point, there is still an
hour and a half until dawn. And honestly,
Muzan may simply realize that this situation is
dangerous for him and he might try to run away
immediately. However, for the sake of the story
let’s assume that he decides to stay or that
they can somehow stop him from leaving. That means
they either need to delay Muzan until sunrise or
cut through all twelve of his vital organs. Which
interestingly there are exactly twelve fighters
facing off against Muzan if we include all the
surviving demon slayers and Kokushibo. So I can
just imagine an unbelievably epic final scene with
each one of them destroying one of Muzan’s organs.
And that could even let us avoid the whole
Tanjiro turning into a demon mess - I mean,
that was always kinda weird in the first place
-which means that because Kokushibo became good,
many more of the Hashira were able to
survive the final battle. But I wonder
if everyone could have lived if another
strong demon were to join their side.
I’m actually talking about Demon Rengoku,
and if you want to know what would happen
if Rengoku accepted the offer to become a
demon, you can watch that video right here.
Thanks for watching and I’ll
see you in the next one.